la preocupación por el ébola se extiende
por África oriental
a raíz del fuerte brote que surgió en
uganda los países limítrofes instalaron
medidas de precaución para que la
enfermedad no penetre sus fronteras tal
es el caso de Ruanda donde el paso de
gatuna se transformó en un puesto de
control para civiles
Ahí es donde recibimos a las personas
que vienen de uganda y que presentan
síntomas de Ébola aquí nos aseguramos de
conocer sus antecedentes lo mejor
posible antes de su llegada a Ruanda a
partir de ahí son trasladados al
hospital de biumba
el área está colmada de carteles
instructivos y explicaciones sobre los
síntomas
a todas las personas que cruzan esta
frontera les hacemos preguntas para
saber si no tienen síntomas de ébola
desde que estamos aquí 60 personas han
sido puestas en cuarentena
decenas de personas salen diariamente
educando hacia países vecinos por
razones personales y ponen en un segundo
plano los peligros significativos que
conlleva el ébola
espero que podamos resolver esta
situación con bastante rapidez Es cierto
que es preocupante Pero qué podemos
hacer tenemos que seguir buscando
trabajo y cruzando fronteras con la
esperanza de que al final todo vaya
mejor
la última actualización de las
autoridades ugandesas confirmó 109
enfermos y 30 muertos mientras el
gobierno impulsa esfuerzos por limitar
la propagación el director interino de
los centros africanos para el control y
la prevención de enfermedades aseguró
que el problema no se está yendo de las